and okays prima is from the IFA
automotive market research institute
welcome is consolidation welcome right
now I think it's pretty much the
necessity for for most brands
technologies moving ahead so quickly
none on different levels so you look at
the car movement you look at the digital
transformation that's happening so I
think that most brands are bound to work
with someone else whether it's
corporation or mergers now that's a
different story and as far as technology
goes there's a lot changing right now
there's the the gas versus electric cars
at the moment which is a really
difficult balance to strike for
carmakers when it comes to costs that is
what's driving a lot of consolidation
right now isn't it exactly exactly
research and development is very
expensive you're really basically
building two different vehicles at the
same time one that is very profitable
and one that isn't at the moment at
least not yet exactly exactly the
numbers just aren't there but yet
everyone feels it's that's the coming a
trend you have to be there you have to
be there quickly you have to get all the
knowledge that's involved understand the
technology and the only way to do that
is to cooperate with others because it's
just simply too expensive and too
complex there's never been this amount
of cooperation in the car sector what
does it mean for the motorist well it's
it's interesting for the motorist
because the brands are need to
differentiate themselves and this is
getting more and more difficult that
also means that more brands maybe on
your top of mind when it comes to
purchasing new cars so there's a lot of
opportunity and risks of course
depending on which side of the brand you
are so that's that's very a very
interesting and exciting time will give
me an example someone who drives a BMW
they love their BMW because it's a BMW
what happens when Toyota is involved
yeah like it is like BMW used to stand
for the six-cylinder in-line engine
they're cooperating with Toyota on
hybrid engines and other cars than in
that sector so you have to begin to
wonder what's what's beyond what's still
genuine BMW
what is Toyota what am I getting it is
very important that the brand's manage
to differentiate themselves and I'm sure
that BMW and toyota have worked this out
before they started their corporations
are both very different very different
and it but they are also active in
different markets so it's not that
difficult if you have players that are
playing in the same segment in the same
market things get a lot more difficult
an autonomous driving suddenly becomes
so much more complicated when it comes
to cooperation you have not just one or
two carmakers coming together but
sometimes four or five exactly exactly
that's the other big trend currently
that demands a lot of time and money and
it's also and it'll be interesting to
see how that affects the brands because
suddenly with an autonomous car you're
going from A to B where's the emotion in
driving now what does that do to a brand
and marketing departments are going
crazy over that because they haven't all
figured it out yet because we don't know
how quickly it is all coming around and
something that's so exciting for so many
people suddenly become so boring exactly
that's exactly the point if your key to
success has been emotion so far the joy
of driving or whatever you want to call
it suddenly there's a car that goes
there by itself and you can be asleep at
the time it'll be difficult it'll be
really a difficult sell the car makers
cannot afford to sleep of the wheel and
Bray as they could very much for coming
in today certainly